I'm Katie bar I'm currently a technical
consultant the test people though only
for the next week
where I mostly do cool stuff in Python
before that I did a PhD in quantum
information where I also did some cool
ish stuff with Python so today I'm going
to tell you about that because I think
it's fantastic the something that a lot
of people find so intimidating if you
have a tiny bit of Python knowledge like
becomes really easy to simulate and play
about with and you can properly learn
what superposition means what amplitude
means you can see interference phenomena
you can see measurement so it's my way
of trying to get my love of quantum
physics over to the masses so we're
going to talk to you about a particular
model which is called the quantum walk
and I'll tell you about that in quite
some detail so that hopefully when we
get to the simulation which I'm going to
rush over a little bit because you can
all just email me and ask if you want
the details I'm going to try and
convince you that this is an interesting
thing to study and by showing you some
really cool applications and you with
the simulation I'll give you a you can
go away and do research that is
publishable like I publish research on
something that's almost identical to
what I go go through with you today
about two years ago so this isn't a
trivial system this is something that is
an open topic of research so I'm not
just giving you a baby thing to make it
easy alright I'm giving you something
that is still of interest to the quantum
information community so the quantum
walk is hopefully what you guessed it
was which is the quantum analog of the
classical random walk
boats really similar so you have a
calling operation and the shift
operation so in the classical random
walk
you just flip your coin that tells you
whether you go left or right and then
you apply your shift operation which is
simply a permutation and then you repeat
that for as many steps as you like they
can both take place on arbitrary
structures so the most obvious example
is the line but you can really run this
on anything and they can be to be
modeled in continuous and discrete time
and which one you choose really depends
on what you want to do so people looking
to model physical phenomena tend to look
at continuous time versions of things
because the flow of time is continuous
and computer scientists we're all used
to like computational steps of Turing
machines and stuff like that so we tend
to look at things more in discrete times
and they're both really easy to simulate
okay the classical random walk on the
line was the first piece of code I have
a wrote the piece of code I'm going to
show you today
it's the third piece of code I ever
wrote so you don't need any skill
whatsoever which for me I find quite
useful and so why did we do this so
classical random walks are used in loads
of algorithms they're really really
useful
quantum computers are known to be fast
and but it's not enough to know that we
have this fast computing system we need
to be do be able to do things with it so
we need to be able to develop
algorithmic tools and like where do you
look for for algorithmic tools we're
quite lazy in academia we usually think
someone's had an idea before so we'll
just go and Nick that so it's all a
classical random walks yeah they're
really useful maybe we'll make a quantum
analog of that and that might be useful
and it turns out it is like if you have
pretty much any problem in computer
science can be mapped or already has a
mapping to this paradigm so it's already
proven algorithmically useful now we
just need
to build a quantum computer to run them
on which I'll also say these exist in
the lab the thing I'm showing you today
has has been run so if you can turn your
problem into something like this then
you might not need to wait around for us
to build quantum computers you might be
able to like modify an existing
experiment and that'll doing a
computation for you so I think that's
pretty cool but hopefully I'll comment
to you by be able to talk so the
system's defined and this goes for all
of quantum mechanics is vectors matrices
and operators operators are simply a
mapping from a vector space to another
vector space in this case we're actually
mapping from a vector space to the same
vector space and I'll use the word
system later quite a lot and to me
a system is just a vector in a vector
space so please don't be confused by
that so I need to tell you a tiny bit
about quantum mechanics and so I'll be
talking about amplitude this is what you
use to calculate probabilities and we
usually denote it alpha and it's a
complex number and that's really
important because controlling
interference and is what gives us a lot
a lot of quantum algorithms are based on
the ability to quant control
interference so if you didn't have these
complex numbers which if you've done any
sort of wave mechanics ever it's just a
phase and then you wouldn't get a lot of
the richness of quantum systems so we
have unitary operators and this just
means validly quantum mechanical so the
time reversible and probability has to
be conserved because otherwise it
doesn't make much physical sense and
orthogonal states are mapped to
orthogonal States so I mean tolds that
in principle component analysis you have
a similar mapping so if any of you have
done that then you can probably think of
these in a language that's much better
known to you so we have the coin state
and the reason for that is to make the
system reversible people originally
tried to make quantum analogues of
classical random walks by just summing
up paths but if you're at position 5
after tie after time 10 times steps and
you have no information about where
stuff has come from you don't know which
path which parts of your amplitude have
come from then you can traverse it so
the quantum the coin state is what
preserves the sort of memory of where
you've been and enables you to turn
reverse it and a time step is literally
just a multiplication of the state
vector by the time evolution operator
and so all we're doing here is matrix
multiplication apart from I'm not going
to show it to you like that because I
promise I'm not doing this in person
with no imports so but fundamentally
that is all that you're doing so the
quantum walk model for an arbitrary
graph so this is just a set of edges and
vertices we have a coin operator
this acts locally each vertex and don't
worry I'll show you this and more
concrete terms on the next card slide
and and it just has to be any unitary
operator if you have irregular graphs so
graphs where there are different numbers
of edges going into different vertices
then obviously you need a different coin
apply to every node and then we have the
shift operator that is simply a
permutation so it's saying if we're at
the eighth coin state of node V then
after we've applied the shift then we
are at the eighth coin state of node U
and permutation matrices are always unit
free so just because they're 0-1
matrices everywhere so to make this a
little bit more concrete we have a
little diagram here so say we're
starting our walk and we're putting all
the amplitude into our system through
this edge here
so we're all coming from the top coin
state at vertex one will apply our coin
operator and we're going to assume it's
a non-trivial coin operator so that's
going to give us amplitude in all three
coin States here and then when we apply
or shift the amplitude in this coin
States that's going to the right it's
just going to be swapped with the
amplitude in this coin state at node two
which is going to the left so hopefully
you're all following so far but I'll
make it a bit more concrete again so
we're going to be doing it on the
lattice and out so that we can use
something called the 4d grover operator
and well I'll show you later while
that's cool but I'm so this we're going
to start in an equal in magnitude
superposition so here superposition is
just a combination of basis States that
just means you're in a combination of
you've come from up right left under all
at once and I've really out in direct
notation which is what quantum
information theorists use this it just
vectors so any combined quantum systems
by taking a tensor product and the
tensor product is pretty much like a
full outer join on a database so I'm
pretty sure that all of you've done one
of those at some point and I'll make
that analogy because then hopefully you
can see why these things grow really
quickly as you combine them and
therefore why they're hard to simulate
on a classical computer and therefore
why we need quantum computers that have
this nature inherently in order to
properly and explore quantum mechanics
so to get a lattice we literally just
combine a line on me and in the
horizontal direction with the line in
the vertical direction and then we're
going to combine that with our position
space so we're going to start like that
and I'll show you that in code in a
second so
the first step will have applied our
coin here will have done off shift and
we've moved in a combination of all the
directions so the second step I hope you
can see I've made this lighter to try
and show that there's less amplitude at
each position but then we have moved a
little bit back into the middle and
we've moved outwards as well and I've
kept this diagram and consistent with
the simulation that I'm running in
general
you'd move out to these nodes and the
ones at the top as well but I also
wouldn't fit on our side but that
hopefully gives you an inkling of how
you get a quantum speed-up with this
thing straight away because our
classical thing and you always expect it
to just get back to the origin but this
thing after two steps it's already
spread out up to two nodes away from the
origin so if you control your initial
state in your coin correctly then you
can get a very high probability of being
measured a long way from the origin in
tea-time steps
so it's ballistic transport and which is
the same in human terms you're walking
in a straight line instead of taking a
random walk so I get on to the tiny bit
of code I don't know what happened to
this box at the bottom sorry
so we we have to initialize the array
that we're going to walk on and our
initial state so to determine the size
you just decide how many steps you want
or wrong to walk for and double luck
because you're going to start from the
middle and if you're going to hit the
edge then you're gonna have some
problems so you need to take care in
that case either by looping things back
to create a sphere or applying a
different operator on yeah and just so
in the easiest case just don't hit the
edge so literally all we have is a list
of lists and each element in our array
is just going to have four values that
are the up down left and right
amplitudes so we're going to set that
I've chosen these particular values
because they give some nice evolution
very distinctive so that's a good way of
telling if your simulation is correct
pick something you know it's going to
give you very distinctive evolution so
to do the time step because you have a
regular lattice like you are actually
you know we're amplitude is going to end
up from each position you know it can
only go up from a certain coin state in
your current position or down from a
certain coins day so instead of having
to do matrix multiplication you just
initialize a new array to give you to
put your intermediate amplitudes in and
the ease of following I've just made
some assignments here so we're saying
the zero state is going left the two
state is going right and then one and
three or up and down and here and these
A's are 0.5 by the way because this is
just the operators that we're giving and
we're basically applying the coin flip
all at once here and so I'll show you
the matrix version of this operator very
shortly but if you remember matrix
multiplication you just take one row and
then you multiply it by your vector and
then that gives you the component now so
this our vector is left up right down
and our row of our matrix is - eh
eh-eh-eh
so we're just doing that directly and
that is going to go into the left coin
state at a new position zero so just run
that for 40 50 steps and you've done
your walk and so I wanted to show you
just again what we're actually doing
mathematically at each name so this is
the four-dimensional grover operator
which is famous due to Grover's
algorithm which will show you very
shortly and so see here Ras was 0.5 so I
really was just taking this row this
matrix and multiplying it by these
components here
that's a first step just written out for
you after the coin flip and their knees
are what get shifted into the new
positions here
okay so there's not really a huge amount
of point in running a simulation if
you're not going to look at the results
of it
so in order to get the results we're not
really interested in the coin state we
only want to know the probability of
being in a certain position and the way
you calculate that is by using me
something called ball rule and and this
is just saying to the probability of
being measured in state I is the
projection of your state vector onto the
subspace re and then the multiplication
of that by the conjugate transpose of
your state vector so programmatically
that's literally just there this here
you times your amplitude by its complex
conjugate so just loop over all
positions and then you have your
probability distribution at the end so
I'll show you some example dynamics and
I would recommend if you're interested
in this that you go away and sort of
look at this yourself because it's
really interesting you know to me it is
anyway this is the simulation that I've
told you about so you'll see this is
dramatically different the other two
which I'll get to in a second you have
this high peak I don't know if you can
read these values here but this is 0.4
this is 0.04 and that's the 0.04 so this
peak is 10 times larger than the highest
peaks these two and you get these sort
of waves traveling outwards as well and
your choice of initial condition
determines how much probability stays in
the center and how much probability
moves outwards so I've shown you these
for comparison this is the discrete
Fourier transform so hopefully you've
all come across Fourier analysis they
it's really hard to see here you need to
really have the graph in front of you
and twiddle it about the this is
something called the Hadamard operator
which is just the 2d Fourier transform
and applied to the left and right and up
and down directions and what you
actually get I told you that to make a
lattice you just combine a line in one
direction and in another direction if
you act just on those directions then if
I flip this over you'd see a cross like
this you've really just got Lorentz
going in two directions so that's
because you don't have entanglement
between the sort of left and right and
up and down directions so entanglement
is just a property of systems when you
interact them they they become well they
become just one system you can't really
consider them as a single system anymore
but it's also useful to look up because
you can treat that as a computational
resource so if you want to analyze this
their own it really depends on what
you're looking for but you can look at
the shape of the distribution so I told
you I've shown you a couple of different
shapes you can get you can see how
different features of the coin
contribute so it's really hard to show
on a static slide but I told you
entanglement between left and right up
and down directions makes quite a big
difference and you can look for things
like rotational symmetry or you can just
look at things like the expected
distance from the mean if you're
interested in transport properties it
really depends why you're running the
simulation and also again it's probably
too complicated to go on now but
entanglement between coin and position
can be quite interesting so pretty much
just stat everything on this slide
so different transport properties that
you can look at depending on what you
want from your walk so perfect state
transfer is literally just going
completely from A to B in some
architectures of quantum computers you
need that to get your quantum state to
the next stage of the computation so
there's a lot of work in that or if
you're more interested in modeling
physical phenomena then you will do it
with the continuous time or in general
that tends to be really difficult so I
would argue against it and if you're
interested in algorithmic properties
then generally you'll write your
algorithm and you'll just run a
simulation to confirm that you've not
messed it up somehow and so if you are
actually want to do research with these
sorts of things
then there are quite a lot of things
that you need to do referees tend to ask
for comparison with the classical case
now because you have a quadratic
speed-up in comparison to the classical
case so you need to run if you run your
quantum walk 40 steps you need to run
your classic classical walk 40 squared
steps so my advice would be don't make
the quantum one too big because
otherwise the referees will come back
and ask you to run a simulation that you
can't physically do on the hardware you
have you can't just pick random values
for the for the initial state and think
that you're going to get something that
actually represents the and behavior so
aggregated behavior of the system
because they're not uniformly
distributed so if you want to look at
sort of well properties of things the
independent of initial state in there
for wrong things for lots of initial
states then you need to do some
transformations
and because these tend to be
computationally intensive I would say
just try not to run simulations because
people prefer analytical results anyway
like if if you think that you've found
something by simulation and you don't
prove it then again your referees are
just gonna come back and say all right
prove it so I only run simulations if
you need so the way I run these was with
a mathematician and we sort of paired
and where he got stuck I'll run some
simulation so I'd say go and look at
this and then we sort of had a really
good relationship where we encouraged
each other and pushed each other on and
so try and find a mascot so to prove to
you the vote on training isn't just some
trivial thing I wanted to mention
Grover's algorithm so we're using the
grover operator this is asymptotically
the fastest possible that way of solving
this problem using a quantum computer so
this is an algorithm to search an
unsorted database and classically you
can't do this in less than linear time
which means basically checking
everything in a roam is as fast as you
can get so it's not too much more work
to get from the stuff I've told you
about today too Grover's algorithm so
you need to work on a hypercube rather
than and a lattice and your hypercube so
the things you're looking for a binary
strings and they're binary strings of a
given length and each point on your
hypercube represents one of those binary
strings you start in a uniform
superposition over all of the nodes on
your hypercube when you apply the Grover
coin every node apart from your marked
node which is the node that actually is
the string you're looking for you run
this for a predetermined number of stats
and then you measure the particle
position and there's a very high
probability that your particle is going
to be where the at the Moret state and
if it's not this is really fast and you
just run it again
so in general quantum computing is
probabilistic so you can't get as a
proper answer out of a single shot of
your computation you need to run it for
long enough to actually get the
probability distribution and and but
that's not really an issue for quantum
information theorists because these
things
I don't know numbers but we generally
talk about things and that evolve in
sort of scales of nanoseconds so if
you're doing and these are for really
large things that you can't like a
thousand qubit and quantum computer
would beat a super modern super computer
so yeah they're fast we just need to
build one that big and I also wanted to
show you because this is cool because it
uses the exact operator that I've told
you to use as your coin operator but in
a different way and this is used to
prove that quantum marks or
computationally universal so that means
that they can simulate anything you like
and the proof has been done via logic
gates so hopefully you're all familiar
with the circuit model of computation
and so I'm going to show you two parts
of the proof I also say having studied
lots of theoretical computer science in
quantum systems it's very easy to get
computational universality so in
classical logic systems it is as well so
you can have a single gates that seem
that's a fairly gate so
it's sort of not surprising if you can
turn this into a circuit that it's
Universal then so we've proved it's
Universal by showing it can simulate in
our elementary gate set so there are a
number of ways that you can do that but
roughly it always needs a two qubit gate
so we have qubits instead of bits so
these are our wires and these you can
tell they're qubits because they're in
direct brackets and so there are a
number of ways that you can build an
elementary gate set but fundamentally I
mentioned earlier need you need to be
able to control interference so you need
to have a way of changing the face of
your and qubit because that's what
determines the interference phenomena
and yeah you need a two qubit guy and
his otherwise if you just had a load of
qubits all on separate wires never
interacting with each other then it
wouldn't really be a multi qubit
computation so I'm gonna show you don't
do really well then only I mean I've
probably forgotten to stay loads of
stuff in that case time for questions so
I can fill in the blanks then so I'm
going to show you how to make the wires
so previously we were applying operator
on something that have amplitude in
every position of every coin state or
just any coin state if you're going and
past the first step of the simulation
here there's a property and this works
for all dimensions if you have an even
dimensional Grover operator so it's
acting on a node of your graph of even
degree and half of the coin states in
your node are equal in magnitude and
phase then so phase is just like a
complex coefficient if I'm making from
losing people with that but I'm
so yeah if they're equal in magnitude
and face and half of them are populated
then it deterministically transfers all
those amplitudes into the previously
unpopulated half of your node so you can
use this to build wires that have two
inputs coming from one side and two
inputs going out at the other side to
deterministically propagate amplitude
across your workers because it wouldn't
really be a great circuit if you didn't
know where your amplitude was going to
be at a given time you wouldn't know
where to apply your logic gates so it
would be pretty useless so I'm going to
show you the simplest logic gate that
there is so you're all I really hope
you're all familiar with the
controlled-not gate it's literally you
have a control bit or qubit and you have
the sort of ancilla bit or qubit and the
control bit does nothing but if it's in
state 1 then the and Sylla bits and
flipped so if it was a zero before and
you change it into a 1 and you do that
literally by just crossing these wires
so that I'm showing these two examples
that Grover's algorithm in the circuit
to show that these quantum walks have
lots of applications in computer science
and you can I did a lot of work on
quantum finite automata and they are
sort of equivalent in quite nice ways to
quite a few different quantum finite
automata if you like cellular automata
then they there's a really simple
transformation that you can do to get
from a quantum cellular automata into a
quantum walk and so and because we know
that Universal might we know basically
that the reefs are mapping from any sort
of paradigm of computation to the
quantum walk if someone hasn't worked it
out
unfortunately you'll have to work it out
yourself and a lot people have done a
lot of work on this so um now a lot
earlier than I anticipated
got to my final slide and so and I've
introduced the discrete-time quantum
walk I really hope that I've made that
clear and not garbled it by rushing too
much because I was so worried about
going over and I've showed you how to
simulate it on the lattice and I've
discussed two applications of quantum
walks and just because I have a little
bit more time there was one more I was
going to put in that I missed out which
is to me the coolest one so I'll tell
you about very briefly and this is the
continuous time walk rather than a
discrete time walk but that just evolves
according to the Schrodinger equation so
you don't need 20 lines of Python for
that you need one import and then do an
undo matrix multiplication sexplanations
exponentiation through numpy but i'm
that is this does this antenna complex
called which exists on a photosynthetic
bacteria that live in really really
murky horrible lakes and these guys they
get one photon per hour if that photon
doesn't go to the reactant reactional
center where photosynthesis takes place
it's going to really really damage the
bacteria think about what Sun does to
your skin now imagine you're a
single-celled organism and you have that
amount of energy just floating around in
you it's going to mess things up so
these things are really really efficient
at capturing might and we have not been
able to explain that classically and we
recently developed quantum mechanical
and models for that and when looking at
the successful trajectories so lights
that goes from the antenna into the
reaction center to make ATP then the
trajectory is a quantum walk so I'd say
but they're also fundamental to life on
Earth and well we'll see because I think
they did some new experiments and got
totally different data than they
previously had so I'm not sure if this
is any any longer true but I'm yeah so
you can use them to model loads of
processes or just talks about computer
science because oh I did computer
science but I'm so yeah I'd also like to
thank Calvin dials for trying to help me
make this talk sort of accessible to you
guys I really really hope that we've
implemented ways that and then Florian
and Ian of helps as well I should have
probably put my PhD supervisor on there
as well you probably don't know her so
it doesn't thank you very much listening
do you have any questions
yeah so okay so I mentioned the quantum
cellular automata as well and then
quantum finite automata and there are
also so these sort of like nouns trees I
don't really know what they are like
people have done work on that so those
are the three main ones that I know of
and then there are also rather than
particular models of computation like
people have done work to implement other
algorithms using this as well so yes yes
they have in fact I really wanted to
troll the person doing my Python
training course because they had a game
of life and I wanted to give them a
cultivation but I'm yeah if you look it
up it's on the archive so yeah well that
really depends and so if you're Google
then you've already bought one that's
d-wave but so people are really mean
about d-wave because they don't show it
to anybody and actually when they come
so does and not a universal computer and
it does this thing called simulated
annealing it takes a month to startup
and then when they compared it to the
classical case it wasn't any faster so
by the time you add the month-long
startup time then you're really hot so
yeah if you have a billion dollars then
you can buy someone that somebody one
that somebody claims is one right now so
as I said already the the walk on the
lattice is implemented in the lab
already
so if you really wanted to go and buy
yourself an optical table dig down into
the foundations of your house and do
some fancy stuff see no vibrations get
through and stand get stuff to make sure
it can be properly dark and all that
stuff then you could do that now but
yeah when it if you're asking when
you'll be able to buy a multi-purpose
quantum computer I I can't tell you that
I think that we'll see a scientific
revolution on the back of these within
our lifetimes but I'm an optimist okay
you have any more questions
okay well I'll assume you're being
sarcastic